so today I want to talk about John Nash
and John Nash is slightly unusual as a
mathematician because he's a
mathematician that is better known to
the public in general mathematicians
bent tend to be known in the public eye
he was the subject of a film called A
Beautiful Mind the film had Russell
Crowe in it starring as John Nash
there's also a book a beautiful mind
that it was based on by Sylvia Nasar I
enjoyed the book more than the film that
filmed a little bit fictionalized I have
to confess I haven't seen the film yet I
know and I'm such a big film fan I'm
such a massive film nerd I imagine it's
absolutely accurate in all respects
because that's how Hollywood works you
may have heard of him because of his
work in economics he won a Nobel Prize
for economics and that was for game
theory so he analyzed what are called
non zero sum games and he's known as
like a father of game theory one of the
pioneers of game theory for a pure
mathematician that was quite a simple
application of those things but the
really big deal was that he brought
those mathematical ideas into economics
but he's really well-known among
mathematicians as well for for some
serious pure math work that he did in a
subject called differential geometry
mathematicians do you think they
actually he's better work is his work in
geometry and partial differential
equations and so it was that work which
was then finally recognized when he got
the our Bell Prize in 2015 well the
mathematician Mikhail Gromov
said that he thought that Nash's work in
differential geometry and on elliptic
partial differential equations was
orders of magnitude more important than
his work in game theory but of course
that's the point of view of a pure
mathematician so I want to talk about
why he won the Arbour prize for his work
in geometry so if we cut off a bit of
square brown paper and this is something
that is possibly well-known to some of
you but this round this square of brown
paper another way of thinking about this
square we add some rules it's called a
flat torus what are the rules the rules
are if I'm traveling along this
paper here and I go off the right-hand
side up like that I then reappear on the
left-hand side if instead I was
traveling up the paper here and go off
the top but then I will reappear ah at
the bottom of the square piece of paper
it's like a game of asteroids and it's
exactly like that it's like a game of
asteroids I'm the old computer games
used to get particularly the game of
asteroids where you'd go off the edge of
the universe and come out the other side
so this is a flat torus it's called now
there's something you can do with this
you can embed this they call this you
can embed this in three dimensions so
this is two dimensions this is a
two-dimensional flat surface but we can
embed it in three dimensions by doing
this right so if I go off the right hand
side and we appear on the left then the
right and the left is the same we're
calling that the same so let's glue them
together and hey we make a cylinder can
you see me there so we make a tube in
the same way if I go off the top of this
torus I reappear at the bottom so the
top and the bottom are the same we can
join them together which is going to be
difficult to do with this piece of paper
if we join them together they would make
a doughnut shape like a classic Homer
Simpson style doughnut it is going to be
difficult we would do with this piece of
paper to show you then I've got
something I can use however what about
that we have the torus shape and for my
next trick here's a poodle so there's
our torus shape and that's what the
shape you want to make so if you play in
the game of asteroids this is actually
the universe that you're living on
you're actually living on the surface of
this universe if in my universe I travel
let's say from top to bottom like that
or I compare that with traveling from
left to right like that
then if I wrap this up like that's not
quite perfect there so if I wrap this up
this is me going round my cylinder
universe and if I can join the the ends
of this tube I would make my torus shape
and on the actual toss itself the green
line would be me traveling around like
this through the hole and then back out
here joining up like that the red line
however would be traveling around this
universe like this
the squeaks are extra so why I've done
is I've turned this flat two-dimensional
shape into in to sit in three dimensions
so it's this is occupying a three
dimensional space there is one problem
with this you see in my square torus
this red line and this green line
they're the same length right because
it's square they're the same length when
I've stretched it into this shape the
green line and the red line are no
longer the same length so there's the
green line going around you see this red
line is much longer now so I had to
stretch it to stretch around the tube is
there a way to embed a square tallest
like that into our 3-dimensional world
maybe it will be a different shape it
might not look like this but can we do
in such a way so that we preserve
distances so this length don't get
stressed and they all get the same
distances that's the question and it
looked like you can do that and why
can't you do that because this is right
this is flat right and the curvature
let's talk about curvature it's a flat
object as a zero curvature something
like this is a curved object has
positive curvature
it looks like it's impossible feels like
we can't embed something because it
would have a positive curvature and we
want it to keep its flat curvature
problem light John Nash found a way to
do it
maybe he's slightly breaking the rules
but he found a way to do it and the
method he found was he was able to embed
the object and deform the object in such
a way that some points curvature had no
meaning he's an example of a sort of
thing I mean so imagine you're traveling
along the motorway at 100 miles per hour
is the accelerate and then you you
continue your journey at I don't know 30
miles per hour something like that so
that might be something that could
happen so this is speed right this is
your speed right against time imagine if
I drew that graph in a slightly
different way very similar graph I'm
going to draw it slightly differently so
I still want the speed up here so this
is me traveling at 100 miles per hour
right that and the end result is I'm
going to be ending on 30 miles per hour
and then I'm going to join up these like
that so they're very similar graphs
there is a difference between them so if
we look at our acceleration right here
there's zero acceleration right you're
cut you're travelling at a constant
speed hundred miles per hour there's
zero exam acceleration he'll the
gradient of the graph is zero here the
acceleration might be let's call it
minus 10 and then here it's it's zero
again
right you're at a constant speed now
with that graph at this point here and
at this point here acceleration isn't
defined acceleration has no meaning here
what you've done you've gone from zero
acceleration suddenly pump at an instant
to minus ten and then suddenly again to
zero
alright and at that point here and at
that point there there is no meaning to
what the acceleration is right you've
gone from 0 - 10 0 what about this now
speed is defined we know what the speed
is here last known problem the speed is
100 miles per hour there and 30 miles
per hour there's no problem of the speed
but the acceleration isn't defined with
this curve that's not the very similar
that's not a problem here acceleration
is defined for every point on this curve
this one's the real world one is enough
yeah exactly that's real world yeah I
agree
and so this is maybe you're taking some
more abstract to look at what you're
doing it works the same in geometry so
if you have something like this then
curvature is defined everywhere here if
we instead we made that sort of shape
was it like a hook if you made that
shape with a straight edge followed by a
semicircle like that then here the
curvature is flat flat flat flat
suddenly here it's positive and at this
point where you join on curvature has no
meaning there's no definition for
curvature there what nash was able to do
was he was able to find a way to embed
your square flat torus into the 3d world
and there are some points like that
where the curvature isn't defined you
can take your flat torus and then you
can embed it in the 3d world and you
embed it in such a way so maybe
something like that you can embed it in
such a way that it's the distances are a
bit short so that your map your your
your deformation that your distances
have become a bit shortened all right
all the distances have become a bit
shortened and then we're going to
lengthen a little bit we're going to hit
this object with waves all right this is
going to ripple across the surface of
this object waves and those waves will
sort of ripple across they were called
corrugations
and they will lengthen all those
distances slightly and you hit it with
another set of waves those waves are a
bit smaller so smaller ripples
but then we're getting closer to the
length again we're getting a bit closer
to what the correct lengths are and then
you hit them with another set of ways
and we get a little bit closer again to
what the correct distances should be and
you keep doing that and then you get an
object which is full of these
corrugations but all the lengths are the
correct lengths as they we're in the
original flat torus are you saying by
making the surface bumpy this green line
has to travel further closer to what the
red lions traveling yes a shortened
distant maybe that correct this green
line would get lengthened so it becomes
the same as this red line around the
outside of the torus so they become the
same length again likely where in the
original flat torus like they should be
so what nash was doing he was studying
this kind of thing and he was actually
doing it more abstractly more general
terms and he was do it in higher
dimensions so much more abstract
mathematics but this would be an
application of what Nash was doing this
this work in geometry when he was doing
this work his solutions involved these
things called partial differential
equations
that's about the rate of change of
things the rate of change of curvature
the rate of change of speed so using
these equations his methods for solving
these equations were so innovative that
not only are they useful in geometry
they tended they turned out to be useful
in the topic of partial differential
equations itself as its own subject so
that is why Nash got the Arbor Prize for
his work in geometry and partial
differential equations
that's right of course his life story is
interesting to all of us because of his
of his mental illness and the fact the
remarkable fact that he recovered from
it to become an active mathematician
again but really his mathematics is
what's going to last